some of the most memorable and legendary
performances in film history came from
those who won the Oscar in the category
of Supporting Actor each of the icons of
the past said a daunting standard of
excellence one that each of tonight's
nominees met with his performance here
are this year's nominees for actor in a
supporting role Willem Dafoe the Florida
Project woody harrelson three billboards
outside Epping Missouri Richard Jenkins
the shape of water
[Applause]
the surfer plumber all the money in the
world
Sam Rockwell's three billboards outside
every Missouri
and the Oscar goes to Sam Rockwell
[Applause]
first
a nomination for San Rafael
[Applause]
[Applause]
run that clock to me I want to get that
ski jet or whatever there was I'd like
to thank the Academy never thought I'd
say those words Willem Dafoe Richard
Jenkins Christopher Plummer Woody
Harrelson you guys Rock you inspire me
and you always have when I was 8 years
old I was called into the principal's
office and my father was looking very
seldom and he said we got to go it's
grandma and we got in the car and I said
what's wrong with Grandma he said
nothing we're going to the movies
my mom and dad's love of movies became
my love of movies so thank you for that
mom and dad I love you
thank you that formidable Frances
McDorman we're at the convention Frances
fantastic Woody Harrelson you guys are
my heroes
this the rest of this incredible cast
and crew incredible Fox Searchlight
everyone involved in three billboards
everyone who's ever looked at a
billboard Martin McDonagh I wouldn't be
standing here if it wasn't for you I
want to do ten other movies with you I
love you Rhonda Elise Jason Liz Mahoney
Liz Hamilton Terry Knickerbocker all my
good friends and my beloved Leslie Bibb
you light my fire baby I love you buddy
[Applause]